توسع العمليات الحربيه ونقل العمليات
الحربيه لمليشيا الدعم السريع الى داخل
ولايه الجزيره ومدينه ود مدني هذا الامر
قد يؤدي الى كارثه صحيه كبيره في البلاد
من وجهين الوجه الاول مدينه ود مدني تعتبر
المقر الرئيسي للخدمات
التخصصيه مقر رئيسي لعمليات الصحه مقر
رئيسي للادارات الاساسيه لوزاره الصحه
وبالتالي هذا يهدد حياه اعداد كبيره جدا
من المواطنين خاصه اصحاب الامراض المزمنه
اكثر من 18000 مريض للاورام يتلقون
خدماتهم بصوره اساسيه في ولايه الجزيره
اكثر من 9000 مريض للكل موزع في السودان
يتلقى الامداد من وسط السودان من ولايه
الجزيره اكثر من 7 مليون مواطن من اصحاب
الامراض المزمنه قد يقود الى الموت البطيء
اذا لم يتم تدبر هذا الامر
والتسهيل حركات الامداد بين ولايات
السودان المختلفه والتي تعتبر الجزيره
مقررها الوجه
الثاني توسع هذه العمليات بالتاكيد قد
يؤدي الى تفاقم الاوبئه خاصه الكوليرا
والتي قد تحصد الاف الارواح من
السودانين